page du jean d'ormesson je le dise en or
me sens une connerie le comte jean
bruneau vladimir françois de paule
lefebvre d'ormesson génial jean
d'ormesson vous voulez toujours dans
votre vieux coupé mercedes
oui lanvin fait toujours pour vous
spécialement son eau de lanvin oui voilà
c'est tout ça dans le sang eh oui
suivent n'a jean d'ormesson j'adore jean
d'ormesson
je le dis franchement et tout de suite
vous incarnez pour moi une espèce de
france est en voie de disparition
malheureusement je crains d'être
moi-même bientôt en voie de disparition
parlez pas de malheur non non j'ai connu
toutes les formes de déchéance y compris
le succès c'est pas une belle phrase les
honneurs je les méprise mais je ne
déteste pas forcément ce que je méprise
la cdu jean d'ormesson
c'est un peu comme la prince ya une
phrase pas de qui elle est tout avoir
pour pouvoir tout maîtriser ces kiss et
barrès ou péguy ou un truc comme ça non
maresches barrette alors le publier
c'est comment on fait un ou publié chez
robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle voilier
commandant ce mets ma blessure
mais je suis bien à senna c'est la
version chic sa réfection meubles bien
alors entrer dans la danse
ça vient d'une chanson entrer dans la
danse voyez comment danse chante et
danse et embrassez qui vous voudrez
cette espèce de quitter déjà tout de
suite dès le titre c'était de fraîcheur
alors vous vous refusez une époque où
tout le monde est dans l'accablement où
elle détient une époque où le bonheur
est mal vu vous refusez tout ça les
jérémiades vous refusez écoutez je pense
que si j'occupe une place peut-être ta
part
enfin c'est pas dur à mon talent mais
peut-être parce que j'essaye de donner
un peu de bonheur aux gens qui me voient
là alors on sait bien que on sait bien
que la vie n'est pas gay tous les jours
je crois que puisque vous avez la bonté
de citer des phrases de moi je crois que
j'ai dit quelque part que la vie était
il fait en larmes et ce livre là aussi
c'est une fête en larmes quand on lit le
boucan sens que vous amusez beaucoup
avaient peint des personnages à raconter
des destins images et des intrigues on
sent un vrai plaisir d'écriture est au
centre du dispositif votre obsession
pour le temps finalement c'est un peu le
personnage qui revient dans tous vos
livres
d'abord est-ce que c'est un plaisir
d'écrire je dirais que c'est très
difficile
ouais je dirais que c'est à la fois un
bonheur et une souffrance eh oui il ya
des pages que j'ai recommencé de 18 fois
ah oui oui vous êtes très bien aussi
oui c'est vrai je crois que ce qui est
le plus difficile c'est de donner
l'impression de facilité est alors sur
l'autre point vous avez absolument
raison je pense que le personnage
principal du livre c'est le temps lui
c'est le temps qui passe qui m'a
toujours un peu obsédé comme sera pas le
seul oui gérer un prédécesseur qui
s'appelait prou ce que c'est et occuper
beaucoup aussi
est ce que c'est le temps qui passe ou
nous qui passons peut-être que le temps
est immobile et c'est nous qui passons
oui n'ont pas le temps malade mais nous
nous en allons d'ailleurs vous avez
changé de coiffure
alors que vous en penser les gens
pendant deux choses sérieuses
un vrai succès ce truc là on s'en branle
un climat la télé par exemple ça fait
moins jean pierre foucault et que je
veux qu'ils veulent alors vous mêlez
très bien la grande et la petite
histoire et des sites crps est un roman
total c'est une ambition tout à fait
louable et très moderne en même temps
vous savez il ya un film dont
quelques-uns d'entre vous ont vu qui
s'appelle la comtesse aux pieds nus
ouais alors au début il ya ava gardner à
l'enterrement bossi et puis on ferait
bogaert qui est là et il revoit tout ce
qui s'est passé alors le lu le livre en
un mot se passe en trois heures dans un
cimetière et à propos de tous les gens
qui passent en même temps on part en
chine en amérique du sud en inde et
tchèques l'antique voilà ça commence par
l'enterrement on enterre romain qu'on
pourrait résumer en disant qu'il vivait
avec talent c'est un ami du narrateur
qui est le grand ordonnateur de ses
funérailles et une amitié finalement
comme celle qui lie deux personnes qui
ont aimé la même femme puisque tous les
deux le marathon heures et celui
commentaire mais marina des belles
séances à patmos je vais vous dire ce
livre est aussi c'est aussi une histoire
d'amour
ouais et alors j'aime écrit jadis à un
livre qui s'appelle vent du soir où il y
avait quatre soeurs et là il y a ceux
remis devant une mère et une fille - et
alors autant de cette merde cette fille
vont il ya des hommes qui tourne comme
ça alors bas lammers et meg opinions
qu'on appelle la reine margot donc est
une collectionneuse de marie damman et
parler ses amants elle a eu lui qui du
piano le chef de la mafia new yorkaise
et si lui qui a organisé en partie le
débarquement américain en sicile du fond
de sa prison et ses les aventure
formidable et alors luciano a tué
naturellement comme ça se passe il a tué
son prédécesseur mais son prédécesseur
était italien aussi et pour le tuer on
disait les ceux qui voulaient le tuer
luciano ce disais c'est pas possible de
prendre des gangsters italien parce que
il connaît tous les dangers
mais on a pensé aux gangs cergy ce
qu'ils connaissaient pas mais alors il
ya une autre difficulté c'est que le
meurtre avait été fixé un saint denis
parce que le samedi les gens étaient en
week end et la gare des témoins sérieux
mais les gangsters juifs on lit le jour
de sa mort son créateur pas le jour du
chapeau alors on a dû changer la date on
l'a fait à mercredi
ça s'est bien passé la fille c'est
marina dont qui a été aimée
effectivement à la fois par minute par
romain celui commentaires ya béchir donc
un musulman qui fait la guerre dans la
wehrmacht et dont hitler empreinte
lampur suicider alors là tout est vrai
aussi mais il clair c'est vraiment
suicidé avec un valter 7,65 je crois
alors vous dire que béchir le web on l'a
peut-être qu'à un tout petit coup de
pouce alors tout le xxème siècle qui
passe à travers des souvenirs croiser
des différents personnages
vous m'avez dit dans tout le monde en
parle finalement le 20e siècle a eu à
choisir vous souvenez de ça entre deux
tragédies entre deux monstres le nazisme
et le stalinisme
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement s'en
était débarrassé est ce qu'aujourd'hui
à l'aube du xxième siècle on voit pas
arriver encore un totalitarisme c'est
non pas encore une fois le fait d'être
musulman mais le fait des
fondamentalistes et le fait de vivre
bien sûr je pense que vous savez le 11
septembre il ya quelque chose qui s'est
terminée et quelque chose qui a commencé
et nous ne savons pas exactement quoi
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya tout un pan de
l'histoire qui est tombée en arrière je
pense qu'il sait pas si c'est ce qui est
arrivé
on sait ce qu est terminée mais c'est
comme c'est comme la déclaration de
guerre de 14 c comme pearl harbour
c'est comme la chute du mur de berlin il
ya un monde nouveau qui commence un mot
là-dessus jours et c'est que je suis
ardemment contre le terrorisme
intégriste et je ne mélange pas l'islam
et le terrorisme sont heureux de
l'entendre dire six comédiens
déjà survenus vendredi entre la vie en
commençant cette émission du canard avec
jamel est la pire chose qu'on pourrait
faire c'est de jeter l'islam dans les
bras du fondamentalisme il faut faire le
contraire voilà il faut isoler les
terroristes et les toros peut venir de
partout
vous savez que il ya eu un terroriste
qui s'appelait abass abass georges
habache le fait très bien
alors il faut isoler les terroristes et
tâcher de regagner tout tout tout tout
tout ceux qui sont contre tu es fort
mais il faudrait pas on peut dire la
télévision il faudrait pas qu'en france
ce soit le début d'un racisme anti arabe
parce que encore une fois ça serait ce
qui pourra l'être
dieu nous en garde je te jure ce qui me
fait le plus mal au coeur et qui m'a le
plus moi de toucher ce qui me fait le
plus peur propos pour l'avenir c'est
l'amalgamme plus qu'on risque de faire
dans les rues je sais que ça va que
l'enfer commence pour nous vraiment j'ai
ce sentiment là j'ai peur pour ma petite
soeur quoi c'est pour ça que jean
d'ormesson du sadc le défi la démocratie
la démocratie ne peut pas employer elle
même les méthodes qu'elle condamne
absolument chemin et donc il faut que la
démocratie soit à la fois forte et
respectueuse des autres alors